so this is super important for us to
understand and think about
we briefly spoke about it on a bonus
show
last week but now that we're closer to
these georgia senate runoff elections
let's dive in even further there is a
contingent of trumpists
in georgia who are thinking of
boycotting the special senate runoff
elections and staying home
why are they thinking of doing that
because they're mad that as they see it
as donald trump has been telling them
the georgia republican governor and
secretary
uh georgia secretary of state haven't
fought hard enough to give trump the
election even though joe biden won it
okay that's
even though joe biden won and trump lost
there are republicans who are thinking
of boycotting
the senate runoffs because they think
brian kemp and the secretary of state in
georgia
brad raffensberger should have done more
to steal the election
for donald trump that's some trumpists
and they're saying
boycott the january 5th senate elections
because we want to punish georgia
republicans for doing that
other trumpist republicans are thinking
of boycotting the january 5
senate election because they believe
it's rigged and just
like it was rigged against trump they
believe that they voted for trump in
large numbers
but because of the rigging they lost
they likewise believe
if we vote on january 5 it also is
rigged so we're going to boycott in
protest there's two different sides
to this boycott now the republican party
realizes
that if they keep calling it rigged they
might inadvertently encourage people not
to vote which will make them lose both
of these senate elections which would be
great for us but bad for them so at his
rally on saturday night in georgia
yes there are rallies and we will get to
clips later donald trump was at the same
time
attacking the system in georgia as
rigged claiming he really won georgia
attacking governor brian kemp attacking
the secretary of state
but also saying and by the way we really
have to vote in georgia
sort of an incoherent message if it's
all rigged and fake and stolen
why is it that people should vote isn't
it going to happen again now i've
received
a ton of emails from our viewers saying
david
you should participate in this encourage
or start
playing up that it was rigged to trick
and encourage republicans into not
voting it would be really great because
control of the senate is riding on this
you should encourage republicans to
boycott get him to stay home
and then john ossoff and rafael warnock
will win here's my thought on this
for more than a decade on this program
i've been calling for
and advocating for and encouraging more
civic engagement which starts with
voting
everyone should vote has been my
perspective and my mantra for years
i believe in total the country is better
off with more people
having a stake feeling involved and and
by the way i think it's better for the
progressive movement
to have higher turnout republicans
know that they do better by suppressing
the vote they have a different view
i don't want that i want more voting and
i want more engagement so
it would be immoral for me to now say
republicans you should stay home because
it was rigged especially when it wasn't
rigged
other than their own voter suppression
which failed to actually give them the
win
so it would be morally wrong and
antithetical to my beliefs to start
encouraging
republican voters not to vote now that
being said
if republicans as a strategy want to
encourage
their own voters to boycott the election
i'm not going to get in the way
this is sort of like i would never wish
death on anyone
but i could at the same time recognize
that sometimes the world is better off
with certain people not around
um i i would never hope that someone
becomes ill or dies
but i can still feel okay saying this
was a bad person that did bad things
were better with them not doing those
things anymore
similarly i believe in voting i believe
in civic engagement i believe in
participation in democracy i would never
encourage otherwise
and i recognize if republicans are
telling republicans not to vote
it might lead to republicans losing the
senate and that would be a very good
thing for the country so
i'm not going to get in the way if you
really did believe it was rigged which
it's not
not in favor of democrats in georgia in
georgia you have the opposite you have
republicans who have purged voter rolls
shut down polling places and all of that
stuff but if you really believed it was
rigged and that your vote didn't matter
it follows logically that you might
decide to boycott the election now in
the meantime
let's not be stupid let's phone bank
let's door knock safely
let's register to vote let's request
absentee ballots and let's try to win
these two races on january 5th so we're
going to take a quick break after the
break
i will have clips for you from
yesterday's debate
between kelly leffler and rafael warnock
it's wacky
and you can find some of those clips on
our instagram as well
which is david pakman show on instagram
find me on instagram david.pacman as
well
you may not have known this but when you
see me sitting here on the show
i am often wearing shirts by a company
called teddy stratford i
asked them to be a sponsor because they
are by far
my favorite shirts that i own with
almost
all other slim fit button-up shirts i've
worn
you get this annoying stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are which
does not look good
but what makes teddy stratford shirts
unique is this patented zipper that's
hidden underneath the buttons which
actually prevents the chest from looking
weird and stretched out like that
it looks really good and just all around
they cut the entire shirt in a specific
way that makes your upper body look a
lot better it's just a much nicer and
more stylish fit
than you get from other shirts and they
hand make everything with 100 percent
egyptian cotton and flat felled seams
which means it's going to be a lot more
durable
than other shirts and last a lot longer
which i really love
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout